hey guys we wanted to take a couple of
minutes to say a few thank-yous we have
had some incredibly exciting things
happen in the last few weeks if you're
watching this on YouTube you might
notice that the video quality is
considerably higher than it used to be
the reason for that is that we had a
huge fan of ours come in and basically
buy us a load of equipment for us to
support the show because he knew that
that's what we needed he didn't want to
be named but he knows who he is and we
just wanted to say a huge thank you to
you first of all for supporting us we've
also had a bunch of high valued
donations come in in the recent weeks we
really appreciate that and again you
know who you are and equally you know if
you're a patron supporting is you're
giving us five ten fifteen quid a month
we really appreciate that it makes a
huge difference please keep that up it's
not enough up your game now we're joking
and yeah sorry yeah we're and but we are
massively grateful for everything that
you donate I am anyway yeah of course
but also as well if you can't donate but
you really want to support us
just tell us leave us a nice review on
iTunes it really does help and by the
way guys we wanted to say thank you as
well the over a hundred of you came to
my Edinburgh Show and saw that a few of
you have seen Francis here in London as
well so we will have more live events
whether that's me in France is doing
comedy or interviews and stuff like that
coming up in the next year or so so keep
an eye out for that and as always thank
you for watching the show thank you for
supporting the show we'll be back very
soon with another brilliant episode see
you soon guys
you
[Music]